Taylor Swift in the news again always
all the time Taylor Swift our undying
obsession with this woman proves that we
really want to live in North Korea let's
do it give it to them the people out
there that you see on the Chick-fil-A
line that loops around and around and
around it keeps going or the In-N-Out
line it goes back blocks and blocks and
blocks and blocks the people that are
sitting that they have the time to sit
45 M an hour and a half for food it's
not good it's not that good they want
someone to worship give them Taylor
Swift she can fall in and out of love
with migrants and the country will react
to the migrant crisis based on who she's
in love with so if she's in love with
like a North African guy you know who
came over it's like hot but if if she
dumps him no migrants then they get
kicked the